hi my name is Richard Potter I'm from
Harper Harper Court at South where I'm
gonna demonstrate m2s link with M 2's
link you can connect Mathematica to SAS
you can import any SAS data set into
Mathematica notebook you can export your
Mathematica data back to a SAS data set
and you can run any SAS program from
within your Mathematica notebook
in addition m2s link has a unique
interactive scatterplot which helps you
explore your data
well thank you everyone for coming I
really appreciate seeing you people my
name is Richard Potter I'm like I have a
company called Harper quartet software
and today I'm going to give you a
demonstration of my product which is
called M 2's link I'll skip the details
about myself those are included in the
notebook that you'll receive but suffice
it to say that I'm a developer I worked
at SAS Institute for 25 years I retired
at the end of 2018 and created my own
company called Harper quartet and the
purpose of that was to create an add-on
for Mathematica that I call m2 s link m2
s link uses the Wolfram symbolic
transfer protocol W STP to connect your
Mathematica notebook to SAS using m2 s
link you can do several things you can
import any SAS data set or jump data
table directly into your Mathematica or
Wolfram notebook without having to use
what are called SAS transport files you
can you know when you import your data
any SAS formats that you have or
user-defined formats are going to be
automatically supported and date time
and date/time values will be
automatically converted back and forth
between the SAS
zero hour and the Wolfram zero hour in
addition to import you can also export
Mathematica data back to a SAS data set
or to a jump data table now not every
type of list of Mathematica data can be
exported back to a SAS data table your
data list must conform to certain
requirements that SAS imposes SAS really
only can recognize two fundamental data
types and that is character and numeric
so if you have a blob or a sound file or
something of that nature you're not
going to be able to import export excuse
me data sets that contain variables of
that type in addition to import and
export m2s link also allows you to run
any SAS program from within your
Mathematica notebook so with these three
features combined essentially what
happens is you can use your Mathematica
or Wolfram notebook as an interface to
SAS so in addition to showing m2s links
import and export and submit
capabilities I'm also going to show its
interactive scatter plot which is unique
to mts link and 2's link excuse me and
that'll be coming at the end of the demo
I will point out that right now and
probably for the foreseeable future m2 s
link only runs on Windows in fact it
requires the 64-bit Windows operating
system it requires 64-bit Mathematica
for Windows and some kind of 64-bit
version of Windows of SAS for Windows
it's compatible with version 11 and
version 12 of Mathematica and it'll run
with any 64-bit version of SAS for
windows like version 9 so the first
thing we need to do is to actually load
or as the terminology goes install the
executable so I clicked on the install
function the line that runs the install
function and that creates a link to my
executable excuse me and because I have
a preference set in my preferences file
for m2s link in virtue of running the
install function it automatically
launches SAS for me and by the way when
you terminate your Mathematica session
it will automatically terminate your SAS
session for you if you want to you can
manually launch SAS just by running
m2s start SAS now in addition to
launching SAS we're going to load a
package that comes with m2 s link called
m2 s link utilities no no what a big
surprise it contains a lot of helper
functions for manipulating the data list
that import returns and it also contains
the definite
the interactive scatterplot so let's go
ahead and import a data set from SAS I'm
going to run the m2 s import function
without any arguments what that's going
to do is it's going to bring up a file
open dialog this is one of the ways you
could import your data from SAS into
your notebook interactively using the
standard Windows File open dialogue and
I'm going to pick the staff data set
click open and in a few seconds it
brings in a list it also opens up this
data viewer you can turn this off if you
want to but it does provide you with a
perhaps more familiar of view of the
data in terms of a spreadsheet style
presentation the actual list that m2s
link m2s import returns actually looks
like this and it contains three sub
lists so let's just go through that
let's look at the entire thing one at a
time the first sub list returned is
table info basically tells you okay what
was the path to this data set on disk
how many observations does it contain
how many variables the second sub list
is actually your metadata it contains
information about the variables in this
data set so you notice that one of the
variables is named first it's of type
character and it's you know can take a
maximum of 20 characters in addition
you'll notice that some of these
variables for example salary and hire
date have SAS defined formats
associating with them so for example the
salary variable has the dollar 10.2
format associated with it which means
that when SAS presents this value in a
data grid it's going to format it in a
special way that's unique to SAS pardon
me likewise for the higher date that's
got a format of date nine this is one
big advantage of m2s link versus using
SAS transport files up until now the
only way you could really get your data
into SAS was either export it from SAS
into some kind of comma separated value
format or use a SAS transport file which
essentially converts the SAS data say
into a comma separated value file in the
process you lose all this metadata you
lose all this format information and
that's a big problem for most SAS users
because a lot of serious heavy lifting
SAS users put a lot of effort in time
and expense into creating formats for
their data because that contains a lot
of metadata for them so they don't want
to lose that and so this is I think one
of the nicest things about m2s link is
now SAS users can get their data into
Mathematica take advantage of all the
wondrous capabilities that Mathematica
has to offer and they don't have to lose
anything you know there's no degradation
in terms of data transfer here is the
third list that's the final and third
list provided by m2 s import this is the
list of actual observations in a matrix
form and you'll notice that as I
mentioned the higher date is formatted
using a traditional SAS data format and
so is the salary field and so is the
higher date now you can get at the
underlying
numeric or date object that is
associated with the formatted string
that you see in this table quite easily
so for example let's extract the
danforth observation in the actual list
of observations and let's go ahead and
get the sixth element out of that
observation which happens to be the
higher date so we get back a string that
says 18 june 1976 we can get at the
underlying date object value very easily
by just
indexing into level two and now we have
the date object that corresponds to that
a higher date so what this means is if
you're a SAS user you can import your
data into your SAS notebook preserving
all of your formats so you
can see okay I'm familiar with higher
dates expressed in that kind of a string
so okay this looks good then you can
access the underlying numerical data the
raw data and play with that you know use
whatever mathematic mathematical
functions you want to analyze your data
so I mentioned that when you open up
your when you import your data you get
this data viewer which is kind of a
spreadsheet style presentation you can
color this in if you want to so I just
thought for the heck of it I'd make the
background green but I didn't in this
particular I didn't set that preference
for the demo unfortunately now because I
don't have a lot of time unfortunately
I'm not going to be able to demo the
user-defined SAS formats but suffice it
to say that in addition to data formats
like for currency and for dates a SAS
user can also define their own special
formats and in order to do that and to
make use of those it's pretty simple you
just tell em to S link where is the SAS
library located that contains these
user-defined formats that's what this
line would do and then when you import
the data using m2s import you use the
format lives option and point to those
SAS libraries perhaps I should back up a
moment and explain that when you specify
a SAS library basically in Windows a SAS
library is simply the name of a
directory so you'll notice up here in
this line m2 s assigned lib name
basically what I'm saying is okay here's
the path to a certain directory which
happens to contain what are called SAS
catalogs these are files that contain
definitions of user-defined formats and
I'm saying please just name that
directory more formats so then I can
refer to things that exist in that
directory using the Lib dot member
notation that SAS invented so here I'm
saying okay my format libs libraries are
found in the library called samples in
the member called formats and there's
another one in the library called more
formats
there's more formats and the name of
that member is gender and when you run
em to us import and specify those
additional formats libraries then you'll
notice that this variable the site
variable which formerly was just a three
character code let's see if I can go
back and see that yeah here it was like
BR 3 BR 1 what the heck do those things
mean well those are formatted code that
are expanded using that user defined
format into these names of places and
likewise gender which previously in the
original data set was just a single
character code has been expanded now so
SAS user formats are actually an
extremely powerful tool and what's nice
is that with m2s link you can actually
access those and retrieve them now I
want to talk about exporting a SAS data
set
in order to do that I'm going to define
a little list of SAS compatible
observations called physicists birthdays
this is a few of my favorite physicists
and I've associated with each one of
them you know a certain record so
there's a last name first name field
there's an age at death field and a
birthdate field by the way one thing I
found interesting as I was creating this
dataset was I was always under the
impression that according to history Sir
Isaac Newton was born on Christmas Day I
think that's kind of an apocryphal myth
because according to the latest
Wikipedia information that's not the
case he was actually born on the
following year January 4 okay well thank
you for I wondered why that because I
have like history of math books you know
I'm a I'm a big thank you I'm a big you
know history of mathematics buff and
even in like I think men of mathematics
by Bell one of the classics it mentions
he was born Christmas Day and I thought
what's going on here okay that makes
sense thank you
ah good well anyway whatever the case
may be in addition to specifying that
list of observations I also need to
define another list which defines the
metadata associated with this set of
observations so I'm telling I'm creating
a list standard type mathematical list
that basically says look every
observation and the data list that I'm
going to export has these fields by
these names with these types and one of
them has a format that I want you to use
date 9 so what this means is when I
export this list of observations to a
SAS data set SAS will record the fact
that whenever it presents this data in
SAS it should use the date 9 format to
represent the date so when I do that
once again
there are various ways you can export in
this case I'm just I'm not supplying a
path or a lib member as the target
destination I'm presented with a file
save as style dialog and now I could
navigate to a directory and say put it
here I will in the interest of saving a
little time I will not do that so you'll
just have to take my word for it that
this really does work you're certainly
welcome to test it for yourself but if
you were to do that then you could of
course run the import facility to bring
it back and check it and make sure that
it's right anyway now the next thing I
want to talk about is the feature of
running a SAS program and importing the
results at this point in time just about
every SAS analytical procedure does
provide some kind of output option that
allows you to preserve the results of
your when you optimize a model let's say
it allow you to preserve those results
unfortunately because these SAS
procedures or procs as they're known to
the aficionado we're not all designed
with the same care in mind or there was
no actual consistency
applied unfortunately and so as a result
the same functionality is presented
under different names so for example in
one proc you might have to use the
keyword out to specify that you want
output of a certain kind in another proc
you might have to use a statement called
output to do that and in yet other procs
there might be another keyword that says
this is some output I want you to
preserve now the thing that's really
cool about SAS is that if you're if
you're familiar with running SAS when
you run SAS you get this output window
that shows you the results of your
analysis and it'll have table after
table you know depending on how granular
you want the results to be you get all
these tables that have all these things
like your parameter estimates your
covariance matrix etc and every one of
those things is actually some kind of a
table in SAS and therefore if you know
how to access it you can grab it and
import it into your Mathematica notebook
so all of the results any analysis that
you can perform in SAS if it generates
any kind of a table of results and
that's pretty much all they do the only
exceptions are those procedures that
actually generate some kind of a PNG
file which is Sasa's way of providing a
plot except for those files as long as
it's a table of data you can import that
into mts using m2s link into your SAS
data set so in this particular example
I'm just going to use the m2 s submit
function to submit a little bit of code
this is SAS code here in the double
quotes and what this little chunk of
code says is I want you to create a
dataset called H H and that's all it
does and as a result when that happen
whenever you run em to us submit unless
you turn it off you'll get this results
viewer that basically tells you how do
things go and in this case there's no
output but there is this log at the
bottom that says ok everything worked
fine I created that data said it has 16
observations next I'm going to run this
program
which invokes proc mixed and what we're
going to do here is we're going to use
that HH data set that we just created
told SAS to create it SAS is holding on
to it we're now going to call m to s
submit again we're going to give it a
different snippet of SAS code and in
this case we're going to tell it to run
proc mixed using that data as input and
as output we want it to generate the
covariance a covariance matrix that
generate excuse me we're going to ask it
to generate a table that captures the
points in the likelihoods surface so
there's a covariance parameter estimate
that's generated in the final solution
and we're going to ask SAS to take that
solution and create a table that sort of
envelops that solution in a surface so
we can see what does the likelihood of
the residual log likelihood residual
look like so if I execute that program
once again I get a results viewer and
this time I actually get back an output
window that shows me okay these are all
the tables that SAS produced it produced
running that model and any one of these
could be imported also I can look down
here it's always a good idea to check
the log did my program work and it says
yep convergence criteria were met so
looks like the model successfully it was
optimized so now I'm going to import
this parms data set that I asked to be
created it's going to contain the data
that represents that log likelihood
surface comes back in this data viewer
like I said before and then I can tell
it okay these are the columns in a 3d
plot that I'm interested in and I'm
using this helper function that m2s link
provides if you call for example this
function and you feed it the data set
that contains your data and the names of
the caller of the variables that you are
interested in it will extract the
columns of data that correspond to those
variables and create this you know
little table
which I'm calling XYZ calls and once
I've got that data I can then feed that
to list plot 3d and you know say okay
here are the labels I want on my three
axes and of course now I've got this
wonderful manipulable 3d plot and you
know there's nothing like this in SAS
the best thing that SAS can do and this
is just a very very recent improvement
in SAS is you can actually generate
plots and some procs but they're all DOA
dead on arrival there's you know you
can't click on them you can't interact
with them you can't do anything except
copy/paste them because they're just PNG
files and nothing more yeah well we
could talk about that offline but not
everybody in SAS in particular the
primary owner dr. Jim goodnight wants
you to get SAS they don't they're not
really keen on you getting jump but
that's a long story anyway final thing I
want to show is yes five minutes to go
great thank you I excuse me I want to
show you my interactive scatter plot
which I'm very proud of this is a
function that I've defined it makes use
of m2s link functionality so first I'm
going to in I'm going to import the
class data set now up until now we've
been sort of brushing aside this data
viewer and you know saying well you
don't need to see it if you don't want
you can turn it off but in this case we
want to leave it up because it's going
to interact with our plot and here's how
that's going to go so I'm just
so I've imported this data I'm going to
specify a list of names in which I'm
interested my X&Y height is my X weight
is my Y and now I'm going to call the
interactive scatter plot function and it
generates you know a very familiar list
plot
maybe the markers are a little bit
different from what you're used to but
what's unique about this plot is it's
dynamically connected to that
spreadsheet window and what that means
is if I want to explore this data
obviously I'm going to be drawn to this
point because that's an outlier it looks
like what if I click on it what happens
well it becomes surrounded by this green
circle indicating ok you've selected
that point and notice over in the data
viewer that row has been highlighted so
now I have a quick and easy way to click
on any point in the scatter plot and
figure out ok - which observation does
that point be long and the interactivity
goes both ways so I can if I'm
interested in Janet I can click on Janet
and now the point for Janet gets
highlighted in the interactive scatter
plot
I can select a group of points if I'm
interested in these points that kind of
cluster together a little bit I can
select them and they all become selected
in the spreadsheet or I can go back here
select let's say dis contiguous group of
points and they all become highlighted
in the scatter plot one of the things
that I have a lot of I'm grateful for is
when I demoed this an earlier version of
this to some of the Wolfram people they
said well what happens if more than one
observation maps to the same point in
your scatter plot how are you going to
be able to tell the user that and I
thought about that I said well how about
this I don't know if this is by design
or by accident but it turns out in this
sample data set that SAS provides us
there are two observations that actually
have the exact same height and weight
variables values and so to indicate that
there's more than one observation
mapping to that I put a little diamond
around that point and highlight both of
the observations now the last thing I
want to show I'll try to make this rule
quick I'm sorry I know I'm running go
over is the fact that you can actually
set markers on various points so that
you can keep you know you can visualize
the difference so I'm going to click in
this column that automatically sorts the
data based on sex I'm going to highlight
the all the females get a right mouse
click to bring up this pop up context
menu I'm going to select a marker that
looks like an asterisk select red as the
color click OK and now all those points
in the scatter plot are now colored red
with the asterisk symbol likewise I'm
going to do the same for all the males
in this data set I'm going to set a
marker and color for all of those let's
see I'm going to give each one of them
two I'll give them the Wolfram Wolf and
I'll make them all blue so this is a
very cool way now I can instantly tell
okay which of those points in the
scatter plot belonged to the men and
which belong to the women well thank you
so much everybody for attending I really
appreciate your coming and seeing here
I'm very happy to announce that m2s link
is now available in the Wolfram store
here is the URL if you're interested or
you can just google Mathematica add-ons
if you're interested in this and I
should also mention that and here it is
a little snapshot of screen capture of
the store with my product after I
released the after I froze the code and
gave Wolfram the Installer and this
seems like the ways to happen this way
after you think you're all done and
everything's been tested and you say
okay take it then you always discover a
new bug and it turned out there was this
bug and the altruist the m2s scatter
interactive scatter plot it only happens
in version 12 so if you buy this product
and you know you have problems with the
interactive scatter plot rest assured
that a fix is forthcoming thank you very
much if anyone's interested
I have flyers if you would like to take
home some information a physical copy of
the information be my guest and thanks
again everybody
you